[Musique]
j'aime sa bonne forme est-ce que vous
avez vu les choses autrement jeudi avec
un certain recul hors de l'agitation de
paris oui c'est évident
paris est toujours un peu d'agitation
ce qu'on appelle la classe politique
dont j'ai pris conscience loin de paris
qu'elle est bien réduite des faut faire
attention il faut y a pas que ça vient
pas que ça il a le bon sens des gens que
j'ai rencontrés avec qui je parle et qui
voient les choses beaucoup plus tout
simplement
alors le recul que j'ai pu prendre m'a
permis de réfléchir
sur un certain nombre de questions
nous en discuterons rentrer à paris avec
mes camarades il ya aussi des choses à
faire je crois vous ne revenez pas
faibli pas du tout je reviens en forme
combatif
avec des idées
[Musique]